hi I'm Dan Romero from farcaster and
this is my network State talk foraster
is a sufficiently decentralized social
network and in 2009 Paul Graham wrote an
essay he makes an observation that
Twitter is an interesting company and
that it it somehow captured a protocol
something like email or the web inside
of a company having spent nearly a
decade in crypto I felt that the ability
to move social media to a protocol based
approach so something similar to the web
or email would be beneficial to society
so forecaster is a decentralized social
networking protocol forecaster exists in
a couple of different layers and so from
kind of an end user perspective you just
use an app we we have an app called
warcast there are many other apps in the
ecosystem Jam is actually a team based
in Singapore and that's a great example
of they are building a client that
integrates multiple decentralized social
networks right and so I I don't have any
say like you know obviously I would just
love everyone just just to do stuff with
forecaster but the beauty of a
permissionless system is the the jam
team is able to go integrate lens and
and other decentralized social protocols
because they think that that's the user
experience that their users want there's
a a recent client called Flink you can
get our client which makes it look like
Twitter and the exact same content can
kind of be reformed and make it look
like the the front page of Reddit or
Hacker News forecaster is a community
not just a utility so forecaster started
as a as a utility this is the Chris
Dixon you know come for the tool stay
for the network most of the people who
are active on farcaster today and who
have the largest audiences on
farcaster didn't know each other before
and I think over time it's it's actually
just morphed into its own Community with
its own set of norms I think where I
have been inspired by apology's Network
state is you know it sounds abstract to
people who who kind of maybe live in in
whether it's web 2 or just the analog
world but if if you really are Cloud
native and and internet native and and
you're building communities in the cloud
first um a lot of what the network state
says it's not just Theory there there is
actual practice to it farcaster is now
adding nft based channels with mods and
what channels are and I and here's an
example of the UI um you can see the
kind of nouns logo here is it allows you
to create a smaller space within the
broader forecaster Network so in some
ways actually a network State you're
able to kind of level up the tool that
you need as as your as your startup
Society grows and and and hopefully
forecaster but it doesn't have to be
just forecaster it's it's this kind of
new stack for cloud-based societies is
able to kind of grow in parallel to to
this overall movement if you send me a
DM on Twitter and you just put TNS in
the message I'll know that you saw this
talk at the network State and I'm happy
to give you a forecaster invite so uh
yeah